هذه العاصمه كياف بعد اسابيع من الهدوء
منذ شهر ويزيد لم تشهد من ملامح الحرب مثل
هذا
نقصت سفاره الانذار هدوء المدينه في وهله
اولى ثم تهاوت بعد ذلك على بعض احيائها
صواريخ روسيه فقد سمع دوي انفجارات في
مناطق سكنيه قالت السلطات لاحقا انها كانت
سبب في انقطاع التيار الكهربائي لقد اصابت
صواريخ منشات لتوليد الطاقه وبات نصف سكان
المدينه بلا كهرباء ليست كيف وحدها فقد
استهدفت القوات الروسيه بالسواريخ
وميكو لايف شرقا واوديسا جنوبا ولذيذ غربه
القاسم المشترك في هذه الهجمات وفقا ما
ذكر مسؤولون اوكرانيون هو تضرر منشات
الطاقه وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي انه هجوم
مخطط له تقول لرئاسه الاوكرانيه استهدف
منشات البنيه التحتيه والطاقه وبات و
احارجه حسب القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه فين
القوات الروسيه اطلقت على هذه المدن اكثر
من مئه صاروخ في المجمل وان الاهداف مدنيه
تطورات متسارعه جاءت عقبه الانسحاب الروسي
من خرسان التي استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه
السيطره عليها وتظهر هذه الصور خلو هذه
البلده الواقعه شرق نهر النيبرو من الجنود
الروس ذكرت وكاله رويترز ان الجيش الروسيه
امر باجلاء المزيد من المدنيين من مدينه
نوفاكو خوفكا ثانيه اكبر المدن في مقاطعه
خرسون وتقع بمحاذاه سد اسراتيجيا يمد
جزيره القرميه لكن بالنسبه للروسي ثم
تكاسب تذكر فقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في
موسكو سيطره القوات الروسيه على قريه
بافليقه قرب مدينه باخموت بمقاطعه وهي
بلده ظلت تحاصرها منذ اشهر